you
Oh
[Music]
Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
holy crap everybody mine below let's
talk about this new Xbox if this is
coming out November 7th and I hit 2
million subscribers by then I'll have to
do a giveaway for one of these new ones
they're pretty hard to get it launched
though I'm sure you guys are like that
you like to giveaways but you would like
a free xbox a whole lot more the big
takeaway from all this especially from a
lot of the gameplay I'll talk about my
favorite games in a second - Carrie Cruz
is a national treasure we should protect
him at all costs is that they're
basically going hardcore 4k VR ready so
if you don't have a VR headset right now
I use oculus it's a lot of fun not all
the games work best on it like the
anthem game looks like it's totally be
already the way they do that intro this
is live gameplay like holy crap this
blows my mind but big raid bites are
just a lot harder when you have all that
be our gear on if you're not used to
doing it that way so if you don't have
it don't worry you don't have to get BR
just to play all these games the other
huge thing is backwards compatibility in
free 4k updates through their xbox
enhanced program so they're really
pulling out the big guns against Sony
Sony has an unveiled its next big
console but they're going to be doing
the same thing to 4k VR HDR so if you
don't have an Xbox one s they said that
that's about two hundred and fifty
dollars right now this will be five
hundred at launch and then in 2018 when
some of these other games they showed
off launched it'll probably be brought
down just a little bit but they showed
off twenty exclusives 42 games total not
all these will be available at launch
they'll probably only have a handful but
my favorite games and I'll play some of
the trailers from each of these number
one was Ori it looks like a Miyazaki
movie just so beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
so sound story are so important to games
nowadays and even though it doesn't look
like it is probably be are compatible
most of the big exclusives they showed
off like the big big games are probably
good for BR gear this is an anthem or
probably my two favorite games from
their presentation
[Music]
freelancer crackling listen trouble big
trouble what did you do mistake I hired
some people they weren't freelancers I
know they said they can handle it and
the price is right
I thought maybe unbelievable you're
right it was stupid
I'm sorry but they're still out there
somewhere if you just bring them back
anything you need
[Music]
in the world of anthem you and your
friends are freelancers the heroes who
leave the safety of the walls of port
Tarsus to explore the unknown and
protect humanity
let's join two players as they head out
on an expedition hey pop you ready to go
grab some supplies already what do you
need today I decided go with the
Colossus I'm going to use my ranger try
out some new upgrades but let me know
what are your favorites in what do you
think about the idea of them water
cooling the console that's been hedging
their bets against future red ring of
death because this 4k HDR just burns
through processing power so no fooling
around but I am so excited about all
this backwards compatibility in the free
HD updates that's probably the biggest
thing in the biggest reason that people
are pissed at Sony because I'm a big fan
of the Final Fantasy franchise Kingdom
Hearts so there's all these great ps2
ps3 titles that you can't really do much
with unless you pay a bunch of extra
money so let me know what are your
favorite games for that presentation and
if you're a big ps4 person like I own
all the consoles I play injustice 2 on a
ps4 but I also own the Xbox s and I also
game on my computer which one is your
favorite now and would this be enough to
make you switch from ps4 exclusive but I
feel like for most people it's just
going to be what all their friends have
like if you play a lot with your friends
and all of them have ps4 stand that's
what you're going to play on but if you
really like this you might be able to
persuade them to switch to the tune of
$500 a pop it's going to be pretty
expensive but it is very much a shut up
and take my money situation so be sure
to subscribe to get everything
I'll be doing more Game of Thrones more
Marvel tomorrow there's a whole bunch of
comic book stuff to get through but
there's a lot of III stuff going on so I
will do III between all the other normal
videos that I would do but while you
wait for everything click here for brand
new spider-man homecoming
you can click here for a brand new flash
thank you so much for watching that's by
five I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]